l'époque des cadeaux approche et
certains se posent des problèmes quant
au choix de ces cadeaux c'est le cas de
ce monsieur mais suivant le
[Musique]
quelques conseils téléphoniques je vous
écoute
bonjour monsieur
oh oui quel âge at elle et combien
voulez vous mettre un financières feront
donc 300 nouveaux france est une
personne qui est coquette qui a quand
même bien les choses pour l'intérieur
oui elle n'a pas beaucoup de
particuliers qui pourrait m'aider par
hasard au elle adore le café mais si
vous voyez vous nous avons ici un petit
percolateur pour l'appartement qui vous
donne du cachet express tout comme au
café et en plus à l'oeuvre glisse et
interco la terre tu marches à la vapeur
comme au café un percolateur qui volait
du café comme à l'italienne et en plus
de ça vous en profitez vous même il
s'émerveille unis 299 francs au dans
toutes les bonnes maisons de
quincaillerie nouma grands magasins et
tout cela et je vous en prie au revoir
monsieur mademoiselle vous êtes
standardiste et une standardiste peu
ordinaire nous sommes là pour conseiller
plutôt que pour prendre des appels
normaux alors quel est votre rôle est
bien à partir d'un fichier qui est
classés en deux catégories
d'après le prix que le client désire
mettre et d'après l'âge les milieu
social le sexe et les goûts de la
personne intéressée
nous donnons des idées aux personnes qui
en manquent
nous les dirigeons vers sata magasin
recevez-vous beaucoup d'appels par jour
oui mais c'est le début de l'opération
et pour le monde je vois à peu près 250
par jour
est-ce en majorité des hommes ou des
femmes qui vous appelle c'est assez
partagés mais je crois qu'il ya quand
même plus de femmes
alors si nous avons des difficultés pour
offrir un cadeau quel numéro
doit-on composé sur le cadran est bien
svp les trois lettres de keller à quelle
heure 8 9 heures le matin jusqu'à 20
heures le soir sans interruption jusqu'à
la semaine jusqu'à quelle date jusqu'au
25 décembre inclus une dernière question
faut-il être abonné à spp absolument pas
c'est entièrement gratuit et ouvert à
tous
[Musique]